♪ ♪
>> Raymond: I'M RAYMOND
ARROYO, THIS IS
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
AND NOW AMERICA'S BIRTHDAY --
GLOOM OR GLORY?
THERE SEEMS TO BE A DETERMINED
EFFORT TO HIJACK OR DISMISS
INDEPENDENCE DAY.
IT IS AN EFFORT THAT WE AS A
PEOPLE SHOULD RESIST.
THE PRESIDENT IS HAVING A PARTY
FOR FIRST RESPONDERS AND THE
MILITARY AT THE WHITE HOUSE THIS
WEEKEND, WHICH IS A NICE
GESTURE.
BUT LISTEN TO HIS VISION FOR
JULY 4TH.
>> BY THE JULY 4TH, THERE IS A
GOOD CHANCE YOU, YOUR FAMILIES,
AND FRIENDS WILL BE ABLE TO GET
TOGETHER IN YOUR BACKYARD OR IN
YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD AND HAVE A
COOKOUT.
WHERE WE NOT ONLY MARK OR
INDEPENDENCE AS A NATION, BUT WE
BEGIN TO MARK OUR INDEPENDENCE
FROM THIS VIRUS.
>> Raymond: DID OUR
INDEPENDENCE OF HER HINGE ON THE
SPREADER CONTAINMENT OF A VIRUS?
I MEAN, WE STILL HAVE OUR
LIBERTIES, THOSE WERE GIVEN BY
GOD, NOT DR. FAUCI.
NOW THE NATIONAL COMMITTEE IS
CONTINUING THIS INDEPENDENCE
FROM COVID THEME AND A NEW AD.
>> AND THIS YEAR, THERE IS MORE
TO CELEBRATE.
THE FREEDOM TO HUG A GRANDCHILD.
TO COME BACK TOGETHER AGAIN.
>> Raymond: PEOPLE HUG THEIR
GRANDCHILDREN AND GOT TOGETHER
LAST YEAR PETER REMEMBERED THAT
JULY 4TH CELEBRATIONS AT
MOUNT RUSHMORE?
AND THAT WAS WHEN OPERATION
WARP SPEED WAS STILL UNDERWAY.
REDUCING JULY 4TH TO A CAMPAIGN
AD OR VACCINE VICTORY LAP
DIMINISHES THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS HOLIDAY WHEN WE NEEDED
MOST.
JULY 4TH REMINDS US OF OUR
HARD-WON LIBERTIES.
EDIT MARKS OR INDEPENDENCE AS A
PEOPLE FROM A TYRANNICAL
OVERLORD.
HISTORICALLY, THE BRITISH.
BEYOND COOKOUTS AND MONITOR
SALES, JOHN ADAMS WROTE A LETTER
TO HIS WIFE ON JULY 3RD 1776
CLEARLY EXPLAINING HIS VISION
OF JULY 4TH.
"IT OUGHT TO BE COMMEMORATED AS
THE DAY OF DELIVERANCE BY SOLEMN
ACTS OF DEVOTION TO
GOD ALMIGHTY.
IT OUGHT TO BE SOLEMNIZED WITH
POMP AND PARADE WITH SHOWS,
GAMES, BELLS, BONFIRES, AND
ILLUMINATIONS FROM ONE END OF
THIS CONTINENT TO THE OTHER."
I'M WELL AWARE OF THE TOIL AND
BLOOD AND TREASURE THAT IT WILL
COST US TO MAINTAIN THIS
DECLARATION AND SUPPORT AND
DEFEND THESE STATES.
YET THROUGH ALL THE GLOOM, I CAN
SEE THE RAYS OF RAVISHING LIGHT
AND GLORY."
WHAT HAS BECOME OF THOSE RAYS OF
RAVISHING LIGHT AND GLORY?
ADAMS WOULD CHOKE ON A HOT DOG
IF HE SAW HOW CAVALIERLY
AMERICANS BRUSH OFF THEIR
BIRTHRIGHT.
A NEW FOX NEWS POLL FINDS THAT
ONLY 69% OF AMERICANS NOW
BELIEVE THE U.S. IS THE BEST
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD TO LIVE IN.
JUST SIX YEARS AGO IT WAS 83%
PER THE NUMBERS ARE EVEN WORSE
AMONG THOSE UNDER 45.
THE BIG QUESTION IS WHY?
PART OF THE ANSWER LIES IN THE
INTENTIONAL RACIAL DIVISION AND
THE TRASHING OF AMERICA'S PAST.
LAST YEAR, PEOPLE TOOK TO THE
STREETS, LITERALLY DESTROYING
THE MARKERS OF OUR SHARED
HISTORY.
STATUES OF LINCOLN, THE GREAT
EMANCIPATOR.
EVEN THE SAINTS WHO FOUND THAT
THE MISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA
RIPPED DOWN THE VISUAL MEMORY OF
THESE GREAT AMERICAN LIVES.
WHAT'S THE SOURCE OF UNITY AND
PRIDE HAVE BEEN PHYSICALLY
STRICKEN FROM PUBLIC PLACES.
NOW IN CLASSROOMS AND POP
CULTURE, ALL MEMORY OF THESE
LIVES ARE BEING REPLACED OR
REIMAGINED.
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE TAUGHT THAT
AMERICA IS THE EIGHT
IRREDEEMABLE PLAYS PREDICATED ON
THE SIN OF SLAVERY AND
COLONIZATION WHICH CONTINUES TO
THIS DAY.
STUFFED WITH DEFORMED HISTORY
AND LUKEWARM MARXISM, THE
ACCOLADES DUTIFULLY REPEAT THEIR
CATECHISM.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE IN A BOOK THAT
WAS WRITTEN BY A MAN -- A WHITE
MAN?
>> REPUBLICANS BLOCKING CRITICAL
RACE THEORY WANT TO KEEP MISS
EDUCATING THEIR KIDS ALL IN THE
NAME OF PATRIOTISM.
TO SPEAK OF MY 4-YEAR-OLD JUST
ASKED IF SHE WOULD COULD PLAY
WITH MY DUMBO TRUMPED FLAG ONE.
AND I FEEL LIKE IT'S KIND OF
PROFOUND.
DID HE RUIN THE FLAG FOR ANYBODY
ELSE?
JUST NEED?
>> Raymond: IF SOMEONE WERE
DEFAMING YOUR RELATIVES, YOUR
GRANDPARENTS, HE WOULD BE MAD AS
HELL.
AND THIS IS WHAT IS HAPPENING
HERE BUT THIS IS NOT A SOBER
RECKONING WITH AMERICAN HISTORY,
BUT WE OWE OUR CHILDREN THE
WHOLE TRUTH.
GOOD, BAD, AND UGLY.
A TASK FORCE AT YOUR NATIONAL
ARCHIVES OF ALL PLACES HAS A NEW
REPORT THAT THE ROTUNDA WHICH
HOUSES THE DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE AND THE
U.S. CONSTITUTION IS ITSELF AN
EXAMPLE OF STRUCTURAL RACISM.
WHY, YOU ASK?
BECAUSE THE ROTUNDA "LAUDS AT
WEALTHY WHITE MEN IN THE
NATION'S FOUNDING WHILE
MARGINALIZING."
BUT THE TASK FORCE HAS A
SOLUTION.
THEY WOULD LIKE TO REIMAGINE THE
ROTUNDA PUT IN PLACE TRIGGER
WARNINGS, CONTENT ADVISORIES, TO
FOREWARN AUDIENCES, AND I'M
QUOTING COME OF CONTENT THAT MAY
CAUSE INTENSE PHYSIOLOGICAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL SYMPTOMS.
YOU HOUSE HISTORIC DOCUMENTS AND
RECORDS.
THEY RECOMMEND THE CREATION AND
SAFE SPACES AT EVERY NATIONAL
ARCHIVE.
THOMAS JEFFERSON MAY NEED ONE OF
THOSE SAFE SPACES, AS WELL AS
THE OTHER FOUNDING FATHERS.
CAN WE STILL USE THE TERM
FOUNDING FATHERS?
AT THE FEDERAL RESERVE, YOU
CANNOT.
AVOIDING CONSTRUCTIONS LIKE
FOUNDING FATHERS, BANDMATE, AND
THOSE BOTHERSOME PERSONAL
PRONOUNS.
IT DIVIDES PEOPLE BY, RACE,
RELIGION.
WE DON'T EVEN AGREE ON A COMMON
LANGUAGE ANYMORE PER THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THOSE WERE
DRAMATIZED VIVIDLY BY THE SAD
SPECTACLE OF OLYMPIC CONTENDER
QUINTIN BERRY.
LAST YEAR SHE MADE A BIG SHOW OF
DISRESPECTING THE FLAG OF THE
COUNTRY SHE COMPETED TO
REPRESENT.
NOT ONLY DID SHE IGNORE THE
ANTHEM, SHE THREW A T-SHIRT OVER
HER HEAD IN PROTEST.
BUT THIS IS HER IN 2015 FOR THE
FIRST TIME SHE QUALIFIED FOR THE
OLYMPICS.
SHE HAD NO PROBLEM WAVING HER
FLAG AND REPRESENTING HER
COUNTRY THEN.
WHAT HAPPENED BETWEEN 2015 AND
2021?
CLEARLY QUINTIN BERRY, LIKE MANY
OTHERS, WERE REPEATEDLY TOLD
ABOUT THE GLOOM OF AMERICA
FOCUSING ON HER PROBLEMS AND
SETBACKS AND SINS.
BUT LIKE THE PEOPLE WHO MAKE UP
AMERICA, THAT IS NOT ALL THERE
IS.
WE ARE A GOOD, INVENTIVE, AND
LOVING PEOPLE.
AND THIS JULY 4TH, LET'S
REKINDLE JOHN ADAMS RAYS OF
RAVISHING LIGHT AND GLORY AND
CELEBRAT